got that yummy yum that yummy yum yummy
yummyy yeah you got that yummy
[Music]
yum goodness me he is uh eating away
right yeah it's surprising to see him do
this yeah um yeah okay meanwhile I'll
try not to get distracted by magnus's
meal it's such a cool image to me these
two top uh sportsmen top chess players
in the world sitting here fighting in a
big final with the you know $25,000 for
the winner it's a trophy and they're
eating takeaway it's just you never you
don't see that in any other sport I
think must be uh some sort of other eort
he's deep diving into his into his
noodles and uh something with rice it
looks like like it he's getting he's
getting shoveling it in there so needs
the energy